[Music]
sometimes there's a glitch in the matrix
where the limitations of the old
operating system are laid bare
and something new pokes through
there have been dozens of responses to
the jordan peterson channel 4 interview
already
what makes this one different
well
i have a pretty unique perspective
in october last year i went to toronto
to interview jordan peterson at his home
you came in from where
i came in from london
last night
i turned the interview into the first
full-length documentary about jordan
peterson's ideas
i was pretty sure he'd soon become a lot
more famous and be recognized as one of
the most significant public thinkers
but i couldn't possibly have predicted
how he'd break through to a mass
audience
a few weeks later peterson did an
interview with journalist kathy newman
on channel 4 news in the uk
a program i worked on as a reporter and
producer for 10 years
it was a sensation
millions watched it online
tens of thousands commented
an overwhelming majority felt peterson
had been unfairly represented
[Music]
and in the weeks since it hasn't stopped
peterson has been asked about it
constantly on the most high-profile
online shows
12 rules for life so without reading
this
so what you're saying is
there's only 12 things you need to know
in life right that's it yeah well yeah
yeah this um this interview that you
just did with this woman uh kathy newman
was that in the uk it was channel 4 uk
so what does this glitch say about the
state of mainstream media
and the culture at large
that's my diagnosis
of what's actually happening is that
people are moving further and further
away from what is what thinking actually
is
and more and more and into merely
running a script
and
what does jordan peterson actually think
that's so controversial you are
misrepresented more than anyone i know
in a weird way you are villainized in a
weird way where um i can't believe that
these people are honestly
looking at your opinions
and coming up with these conclusions i
believe this encounter struck such a
nerve because it's a cultural watershed
moment seen properly as peterson would
say it's archetypal in that it contains
layers and layers of meaning
that go right to the heart of the
biggest rifts we're seeing playing out
in the culture
over the next 50 minutes i'm going to do
my best to unpack it
from the clash between new and old media
this is also why youtube is going to
kill tv
because television by its nature all of
these narrow
broadcast
technologies they re they rely on
forcing the story all the way down to
the mythological and archetypal level i
thought of ideologies as fragmentary
mythologies that's where they get their
archetypal and psychological power in
the postmodern world and this seems to
be something that's increasingly seeping
out into the culture at large you have
nothing but the tyrannical father
nothing but the destructive force of
masculine consciousness and nothing but
the benevolent
benevolent great mother and it's a it's
an appalling ideology and it seems to me
that it's sucking the vitality which
which is exactly what you would expect
symbolically it's sucking the vitality
of our culture and to ask how do we move
forward constructively rather than just
adding to the polarization
i've been a journalist for 16 years
in the newsrooms of the bbc in channel 4
and then making documentaries
i moved away from the front line of news
some time ago and started learning
psychology
which is what first drew me to jordan
peterson
from a distance i've started to see the
blind spots of the establishment media
much more clearly i spent some of the
best years of my working life at channel
4 news and have a huge amount of respect
and gratitude to the program
but i'm making this film because i feel
so strongly that if we can't have open
conversations about the kind of topics
peterson is raising
we're in serious trouble
[Music]
peterson is one of a new breed of
thinkers made famous almost completely
by the internet not the broadcast media
part of a powerful new informal network
being called the intellectual dark web
the mainstream media is based on an old
dying model that is being replaced by
new media and new technology so quickly
that its faults are becoming glaringly
obvious fortunately thanks to youtube
podcasting and however else you get
shows like this one the mainstream media
stranglehold on information which really
is a stranglehold on your ability to
think clearly about the issues of the
day is crumbling at an incredible rate
now the question is who and what will
replace it a few months ago one of my
favorite people to sit across this table
from eric weinstein came up with the
phrase intellectual dark web to describe
this eclectic mix of people from sam
harris to ben shapiro to his brother
brett weinstein to jordan peterson all
of whom are figuring out ways to have
the important and often dangerous
conversations that are completely
ignored by the mainstream it's why i
would argue that this collection of
people are actually more influential at
this point than whatever collection of
cable news pundits you can come up with
if you think i'm being hyperbolic about
the growing influence of this group just
check the traction that these people get
on twitter or facebook compared to our
mainstream competitors twitter may not
be real life as i say in my twitter bio
but it is some barometer of what the
zeitgeist is right now what unites this
group of thinkers is a sense that the
set of ideas that have run western
culture for years are breaking down
and that the chaos of the moment is the
attempt to find new ones
it's nearly all happening online part of
the problem that we have right now in
our culture is trying to diagnose the
level at which the discussion should be
taking place and i think the reason that
this is a tumultuous time is because it
actually is a time for discussion of
first principles and it's it's that and
first principles are virtually at the
level of theology right because first
principles are the things that you
assume
and then move forward it's like well
what should we assume well the dignity
of the human soul let's start with that
you can't treat yourself properly
without assuming that you can't have a
relationship with another person you
can't stabilize your family you can't
have a functional society so what does
it mean for this human soul to have
dignity well
the part of the idea is that you're
participating in creation itself and you
do that with your actions and your
language and you get to decide whether
you're tilting the world a bit more
towards heaven or a bit more towards
hell and that's actually what you're
doing so that's a place where the
literal and the metaphorical truth comes
together and people are very
they're terrified of that idea as they
should be because it's a massive
responsibility they also argue that the
central problem is polarization
boosted by social media
peterson's work looks at how people are
hardwired to see the world differently
a lot of what determines your political
orientation is
biological temperament
far more than people realize so for
example
left-leaning people
liberals let's say although that's kind
of
misnomer but
we'll keep with the terminology liberals
are high in a trait called openness
which is one of the big five personality
traits and it's associated with interest
in abstraction and interest in
aesthetics it's the best predictor of
liberal political leaning and they're
low in trait conscientiousness which is
dutifulness and
and orderliness in particular
whereas the conservatives are the
opposite they're high in
conscientiousness they're dutiful and
orderly and they're low in openness and
that makes them really good managers and
administers administrators and often
businessmen but not very good
entrepreneurs
because the entrepreneurs are almost all
drawn from the liberal types
and so these are really fundamental
fundamentally biologically predicated
differences and there you might think
about them as different sets of
of opportunities and limitations and and
certainly different ways of screening
the world and each of those different
temperamental types needs the other type
let's call this a diversity issue if you
start understanding that the person that
you're talking to who doesn't share your
political views
isn't
stupid that's the first thing
necessarily they might be but so might
you be you know stupidity isn't the
differences in intelligence are not the
prime determinant of differences in
political belief
all right so you might be talking to
someone who's
more conscientious and less creative
than you if you're if you happen to be a
liberal but that doesn't mean that that
person's perspective is not valid and it
doesn't mean that they wouldn't
outperform you in some domains because
they would so one thing to remember is
people actually do see the world
differently it's not merely that they
that they're possessed of of of
ill-informed opinions
the whole point of the of a democracy is
to continue the dialogue between people
of different temperamental types so that
we don't move so far to the right that
everything becomes encapsulated and
stone and doesn't move or so far to the
left that everything dissolves in a kind
of mealy-mouthed chaos
and the only way that you can you can
navigate between those two shoals is by
is through discussion which is why free
speech is such an important value it's
the thing that keeps the temperamental
types from being at each other's throats
in the aftermath of the trump election
that came as such a shock to most of the
media one of the most widely shared
analysis pieces was from deep code
it describes how the establishment
mainstream media perspective
based around liberal values of openness
and inclusivity
he calls the blue church
is being challenged by a new web-based
insurgency
a red religion
based on the values of tribalism
the culture war of the the 20th century
was a decisive
success for blue and a
effectively a route for red
so what we see first is that red was
forced to move into a deeply exploratory
phase
second
that it did this in a context where as
it turns out
things were changing meaningfully quite
significantly in fact from my
perspective in a world historical level
the emergence of entirely new forms of
communication and therefore entirely new
forms of sense-making and coherence
he concludes that the blue church is in
the process of collapse
as its dominant ideology can't adapt to
changing reality
but that a combination of the two sets
of values of blue and red is essential
we
are conscious
and effective in the world
in groups not as individuals and the
ingredients of those groups
include aspects that are currently
showing up as both red and blue
i propose
somewhat
strongly
that
neither red nor blue as pure
elements contain the ingredients
necessary to actually be adaptive to
reality
um this is a disaster in fact
um it's a little bit like
separating the hand and the eye and you
the eye can see if the eye takes itself
as being the essence of virtue it
separates itself from the ability to do
the same thing with the hand for
most of human history these groups have
actually always co-mingled they're
necessary that they actually relate to
each other in a deeply healthy uh and
direct fashion
uh their separation into armed camps is
extinctionary actually what are the
values of red that you think blue needs
to integrate or to make or to
reintegrate
oh oh that's actually pretty easy
responsibility i mean we've actually
even seen it um
the ability to
make a commitment and keep it
which by the way ideologically shows up
as either duty or loyalty but those are
both ideologies the the deeper sense is
that ability
um
[Music]
responsibility both the individual and
the group level the ability to actually
really make a personal sacrifice on the
part of the group that's actually a
deeply
red value
and i don't mean that by the way
as
politically ideological
certainly there are people who
are currently part of blue who
feel that deeply what i'm saying is that
that shows up much much more intensely
in
red and when you're feeling it in blue
you're actually feeling a red value and
that's good mixing is crucial
um
because that's very jordan peterson
asked to do how would you how would you
define jordan peterson or do you think
the fact that
the issue is that he is is not definable
within one of those two camps yeah i
think that's the point i think that he
grasps directly the fact that human
beings can only actually make sense of
the world by virtue of
communication with other human beings
and this is all about the notion of
admixture that one must have a mixture
of
of well i mean he uses the mythopoetic
to make sense the order order and chaos
uh the way right the taoist way is the
alchemical admixture of order and chaos
and that's it like that's how you do it
and so if you
bias towards orderliness
uh you find yourself in a
rigid non-adaptive
uh non-creative non-exploratory
framework
which will die because the world changes
if you buy us towards chaos um you you
eat your young and evaporate um which
also dies for obvious reasons uh and the
key is to actually enable these things
to be in relationship with each other in
vital healthy relationship with each
other and i think that's in some sense
the essence of what he's
focusing on and is sort of the core of
what he's actually about peterson is
hard for the broadcast media to get a
handle on because the depth of his
thought means he doesn't fit easily into
any of their categories
the clash with kathy newman was his
breakthrough moment
where the new world met the old
to give the context from kathy newman's
side she has to do dozens of interviews
each month
peterson is hard to get a grip on
and he sure as hell looks controversial
she's also focused on getting sound
bites for a five minute cut down of the
interview for tv
not a long conversation for online
the interview was ridiculous it was a
ridiculous interview and i listened to
it or watched it several times i was
like this is so strange it's like her
determination to turn it into a conflict
to
it's one of the issues that i have with
television shows because they have a
very limited amount of time and they're
trying to make things as salacious as
possible they want to have these sound
bites these click bait sound bites and
she just
went into it incredibly confrontational
not trying to find your actual
perspective but trying to force you to
defend a non non-realistic perspective
yes well i was the i was the
hypothetical villain of her imagination
essentially now this is also why youtube
is going to kill tv
because television by its nature all of
these narrow broadcast
technologies they re they rely on
forcing the story right because it has
to happen now it has to happen in like
often in five minutes because they only
broadcast five minutes of that in
interview they did put the whole thing
up on youtube to their credit yep
it it it hasn't ceased to amaze me yet i
think that
they thought that the interview went
fine
after the interview channel 4 news found
themselves at the center of an online
storm which included some nasty personal
and misogynistic attacks
it's understandable that they just
wanted it to go away
but online is forever
and as the center of gravity continues
to shift away from traditional media
this interview is i would argue
a slow motion and continuing car crash
for channel 4's credibility
so why did it happen
partly the limitations of the medium of
tv
but also because of the institutional
political blindness of the mainstream
media
i've always considered myself of the
liberal left but especially since the
election of trump i've been trying to
understand what happened
and i'm convinced that the polarization
we're seeing is mainly driven by the
shadow side of liberalism in particular
where supposedly inclusive social
justice liberalism stops being inclusive
and secretly judges and despises people
that don't think the same way
the rebellion of trump and brexit was a
direct response
as uri harris argues in this article in
colette
the new gatekeepers of the media have
become a new bourgeoisie enforcing a
rigid etiquette and using the rights of
the oppressed as an excuse to put
forward a vision of the kind of society
they personally want to live in
on the surface level it's about how a
narrow social justice worldview embodied
by kathy newman in the interview became
the new status quo
and how this institutional bias of much
of the mainstream media means it can't
see or understand the forces that are
challenging this new consensus
the counterculture used to be on the
left
but once it won the culture war
it left space for a new counterculture
the biggest manifestation is the red
pill phenomena which the mainstream
media mistakenly assumes is the same
thing as the alt-right i was surprised
to just discover the overlap between
um
what i'm into
particularly like
greek philosophy and stoicism
and
the alt-right who i'd always thought of
you know if i come across the tour i
thought them as kind of
um
swivel-eyed bogeymen you know uh
completely unpalatable extremists uh in
their in their basements
and then to discover that um
you know a lot of them were a lot of
people in stoicism were also really into
the alt-right
made me wonder
what was going on and why people like me
were getting radicalized
and drawn into it could you explain what
stoicism is for
um
stoicism is basically
an ancient greek philosophy
which um was became very popular in the
roman empire
uh you know with like the the emperor
marcus aurelius was a stoic for example
and it's in some ways like a western
form of buddhism it's like a therapy for
the emotions it teaches you to take
responsibility for your thoughts to take
and thereby to take some control over
your emotions
so
in some ways it's putting forward a
model of
strength and integrity and kind of
resilience
uh amid adversity and rapid change so
for that reason it's become very popular
in the last uh 10 years
i i think this is also why from my
perspective at least someone like jordan
peterson
is often looked from the outside as
being aligned with the alt-right because
he has a similar message but it's but
there are crucial differences i think
between what we would consider
i mean certainly white nationalism would
be an essential part of the alt-right i
would say of any useful definition
and yeah that's that's certainly not
characteristic of jordan peterson from
my experience no there's there's a
crucial difference at least between
stoicism and the alt-right uh even
though a lot of alt-right is into
stoicism in that stoicism and and
maybe jordan peterson as well i don't
i'm not an expert on him talk about
the way to gain strength
and maturity and power
is internal it's to take responsibility
for your own thoughts and feelings
whilst i think people sometimes men
might look for that sense of power and
control externally
by um suppressing
or
or or segregating anyone who they feel
threatened by whether that's other
colors or other sexualities or or gender
so there's a crucial difference there
one is about kind of inner integrity uh
and and and just kind of um being strong
within yourself and the other is about
trying to take control through the kind
of exterior borders and fences if you
see what i mean every public appearance
that i've made that's related to the
sort of topics that we're discussing is
overwhelmingly men
it's like it's like 85 to 90 percent and
so i thought wow that's weird like what
the hell's going on here exactly and
then the other thing i've noticed is
that
i've been talking a lot to the crowds
that i've been talking to not about
rights but about responsibility right
because you can't have the bloody
converse why do you do it you can't have
the conversation about rights without
the conversation about responsibility
because your rights are my
responsibility that's what they are
technically so you just can't have only
half of that discussion and we're only
having half that discussion the question
is well what the hell are you leaving
out if you only have that half of the
discussion
and the answer is well you're leaving
out responsibility and then the question
is well what are you leaving out if
you're leaving out responsibility and
the answer might be well maybe you're
leaving out the meaning of life
that's what it looks like to me it's
like here you are
suffering away what makes it worthwhile
right
you know you're completely out you're
completely you have no idea what you're
you it's almost impossible to describe
how bad an idea that is
responsibility
that's what gives life meaning
it's like lift a load
then you can tolerate yourself right
because look at you're useless
easily hurt easily killed why should you
have any self-respect that's the story
of the fall
pick something up and carry it pic make
it heavy enough so that you can think
yeah well useless as i am at least i
could move that from there to there well
what's really cool about that is that
when i talk to these crowds about this
the men's eyes light up
and that's very like i've seen that
phenomena because i've been talking
about this mythological material for a
long time and i can see when i'm
watching crowds people you know their
eyebrows lift their eyes light up
because i put something together for
them that's what mythological stories do
so i'm not taking responsibility for
that that's what the stories do so i say
the story people go click click click
you know when their eyes light up but
this responsibility thing that's a whole
new order of this is that young men are
so hungry for that it is unbelievable it
just blows me away it's like really
that's what's
that's the counterculture
grow the hell up and do something useful
really i could do that oh i'm so excited
by that idea no one ever mentioned that
before it's like rights rights rights
rights jesus it's it's it's appalling
it's
and and i feel that that's deeply felt
by the people who are
who are coming out to
to listen to these sorts of things too
they've had enough of that
so and they better have because it's
it's a non-productive mode of being
responsibility man peterson is part of
the counterculture but he describes
himself as a classic liberal and yet
he's frequently described as right wing
by the media
this is not limited to peterson
james damore's infamous google memo was
described everywhere as an
anti-diversity screed
despite him specifically stating he
wanted to encourage more diversity in
the workplace
many believe that the channel 4
interview was a significant moment in
exposing this mindset as dogmatic
reactionary and fixed so during the
interview we see an example of
um a delusional framework that is
what appears to be largely incapable of
perceiving and reacting to reality in
real time
but much more interesting is what
happened afterwards which was the sort
of the self-healing and policing
mechanism of the larger social consensus
of how when how the blue church
reactively
goes about maintaining the integrity of
its frame
and so it ended up happening was there
was a break in the frame there was a
glitch in the matrix
the uh
mechanisms of the blue church reacted to
endeavor to control the frame and to
convert it into a way of sense of uh
making sense of the what occurred that
still maintained the integrity of its
frame
do you mean when they tried to
characterize it as as sort of
abusive trolls and the alt-right hero
and all of that exactly
exactly sort of a
to use a military language it was a
fallback position that was a reactive
almost instinctual and not almost in
fact precisely instinction was that pure
habit
there was no
uh
thoughtfulness or even um
strategic
action there it was
if
if x then y and in this case y is here's
a set of things that one does to
re-establish the dominant frame
and now we're now we're two levels deep
in the first level was a
sort of self-evident disaster but then
the second level was also a relatively
self-evident disaster and
there isn't really a third level
in this approach so it ends up happening
and this is again you can kind of just
think about this from
ordinary psychology
um
this is how delusions fall apart as we
try as we might our desire to interpret
reality to mean what we want it to mean
at the end of the day we'll always
be checked against what reality actually
is
it may be some time you know we're
pretty good at
making things up and pretending but
eventually reality is reality this isn't
to say that peterson is not
controversial
he's saying things that challenge the
most deeply held assumptions of the new
establishment narrative i guess the
other reason that people are
on my case to some degree is because i
have made a strong case which i think is
fully documented by the scientific
literature that there are intrinsic
differences say between men and women
and i think the evidence in that this is
the thing that staggered me is that
no serious scientists have debated that
for like four decades
it's that argument was done
by the time i went to graduate school
everyone knew that human beings were not
a blank slate that biological forces
not
parameterized the way that we thought
and and felt and acted and and and
valued everyone knew that the fact that
this has become somehow debatable again
is just
especially because it's being done by
legislative fiat they're forcing it
part of peterson's argument based on
years of psychological research
is that much of the political conflicts
are due to trying to integrate the
different political temperaments of men
and women
we were talking about the relatively the
relative evolutionary roles of men and
women this is speculative obviously and
and
because our research did indicate it's
tentative research so far that that the
the the sgs sjw sort of equality above
all else philosophy is more prevalent
among women
it's predicted by the personality
factors that are more common among women
so agreeableness and high negative
emotion
primarily agreeableness but in addition
it's also predicted by being female
and so i've been thinking about that a
lot because
well men are bailing out of the
humanities like mad and pretty much out
of the universities except for stem the
women are moving in like mad and they're
also moving into the political sphere
like mad and this is new right we've
never had this happen before and we do
know do not know what the significance
of it is it's only 50 years old
and so we were thinking about this and
so i don't know what you think about
this proposition but
imagine that that historically speaking
it's something like
women were responsible for distribution
and men were responsible for production
something like that and maybe maybe
that's only the case really in the tight
confines of the immediate family but
that doesn't matter because that's most
of the evolutionary landscape for human
beings anyways what the women does it
did was make sure that everybody got
enough
okay and that seems to me to be one of
the things that's driving at least in
part the sjw demand for for equity and
equality it's like let's make sure
everybody has enough it's like well look
fair enough you know i mean you can't
you can't argue with that but there's
there's an antipathy between that and
the the reality of differential
productivity you know because people
really do differ in their productivity i
think that the sjw phenomena is
different and i think it is associated
at least in part with the rise of women
to political power and and
we don't know what women are like when
they have political power because
they've never had it
i mean there's been queens obviously and
that sort of thing there's been female
authority figures and females have
wielded far more power historically than
feminists generally like to admit but
this is a different thing and we don't
know what what a truly female political
philosophy would be like but it might be
especially if it's not been well
examined and it isn't very sophisticated
conceptually it could easily be well
let's make sure things are distributed
equally
well yeah but sorry that's just knocking
up do you fly
[Music]
one of peterson's main influences is the
psychologist carl
young psychology was built around the
concept of the shadow
all the things about ourselves we don't
want to accept
our anger negativity unconscious
judgments
and how we need to integrate all those
disowned parts to grow
i'm convinced that's what's happening on
a vast cultural level
since leaving channel 4 news i've
retrained as a counsellor and started
leading personal growth workshops for
men
and thought a lot about how these
unconscious gender dynamics are playing
out in the culture
one of the central concepts is jung's
idea of animus and anima possession
how we each have both an inner masculine
and feminine essence
in a man when he's unconsciously
possessed by his feminine side his anima
he becomes withdrawn moody and reactive
and when a woman is possessed by her
male side the animus
she becomes aggressive and dominating
and how many women are pushed into that
by the nature of the modern workplace
the kathy newman i know is warm
compassionate a successful and talented
journalist none of this is criticism of
her just the role she was playing in the
interview life has been
moving forward for three and a half
billion years and
it moves forward in these patterned
manners like the dominance hierarchy for
example so that's that let's call that
the masculine archetype it's part of the
masculine archetype
in fact jung's
proclamation was that the female
representation of the male
so that's the animus is the
dominance hierarchy it's the patriarchy
so that's the that's the unconscious
archetype which i think is extremely
interesting given what's happened say in
the women's movement because that's
what's projected on to men
and
and it can be projected in a very
negative way it doesn't have to be but
it can be and so an animus possessed
woman treats a man as if he's the
manifestation of the tyrannical
patriarchy he's a group he's the group
of men
yeah the group of bad men actually you
watched the jordan peterson cathy newman
interview what did you what did you
think
oh i my whole body contracted and i i
felt
so
sad for womanhood
i felt
disappointed and
i could see how
the shadow part of womanhood was acting
out i could see how the collective rage
was acting through kathy newman and this
is what happens is that when that's
unowned it's projected blindly onto
whatever stick wherever it sticks
and it was very clear that she already
had an agenda and she already had a
projection that she was just
looking to stick she was she was just
looking to have that confirmed
so i felt on behalf of women i felt sad
and disappointed because we need to have
intelligent conversations and i also
want to say that this isn't
even though the the specific example is
that cathy newman jordan peterson
interview it's not specific to
to kathy newman i think the fact that
that interview has resonated with so
many people that's been so popular shows
that actually something
archetypal was going on in that in that
interaction and i think
as well
why it's gone viral is
a lot of people watching it recognize
those dynamics they're like i've been in
conversations like that
i've been in this conversation where
nothing i say works where nothing i say
gets through
so there's something sort of fundamental
about about the masculine feminine
dynamic that's going on in there what do
you think that is i think jordan
peterson he's every man kathy newman
she's every woman i can tap into that
rage like this i know it in myself and
women that say they don't they're just
denying it because it is in the
collective
so in that sense it just highlighted
what what's there it's wonderful because
here we really get to look at why is
this so important why is it so important
to listen to
to a thinker like jordan peterson and
take it seriously and say what can we do
with it it's just so obvious that it's
needed because if this is where we are
if this is where society and culture is
is if this is the ability to have an
intelligent conversations conversation
then we are in trouble i really feel
that there is this collective
subconscious rage that is just
boiling in women
and it's coming up in so many ways we
see we see in the media and and
what's going on is this
unowned rage that comes up in in many
different ways
um
and on one hand it needs to come out we
need to clear it it needs to be
expressed it needs to be acknowledged on
the other hand
it's not enough this is only like this
is breaking the ice
so that
the next step of evolution can
you know
consciousness can start coming through
and that's what i'm lacking in women
it's really to take responsibility for
what we do as women
in our manipulation in our seduction in
our control
and and it's so easy for women to say
but that's just because we're angry and
men did this and patriarchy but it's um
it's such a lack of responsibility and
this
women really need to know i mean that's
the the kind of shadow work is
the acceptance that we all have shadows
that men certainly have a shadow there
is a shadow around masculinity
but there's also a shadow around
femininity and while part of the
cultural conversation now is toxic
masculinity and everyone knows what you
mean by toxic masculinity
if you talk about toxic femininity
everyone still knows what you mean but
you can't have that conversation which
is it's it's interesting what is allowed
to be said and what is not allowed to be
said at the moment and that that i think
is
is very
dangerous that certain topics certain
conversations are off are off limits and
this is where we see
where we see the victim persecutor
dynamics activated because women become
the become the victims and we make
ourselves the victims and we persecute
men but in that aggression in that rage
and when we are the victims we are in
perfect control we become the
persecutors because we we say
it's all about blame
men do this and men need to take
responsibility but in that we become the
persecutors and it's also very difficult
as well because one imagines that
that
combative attitude is something that has
served her well in the past and it's
something that she's maybe felt forced
into because of the nature of the
society that she's operating in so it's
a kind of catch-22 situation for for
many successful women because they feel
that they're pushed to be more masculine
and then when they're more masculine
they get judged for being more masculine
it's it's very sad and and and i can see
that dynamics being played out
absolutely but i think the only thing we
can do is to take responsibility and say
okay i'm doing that do i really want to
compromise my femininity do i want to
compromise my integrity do i want to
compromise my gender and play that or is
there another way that i can be powerful
without being aggressive without playing
a power game but resting in my natural
power resting in my natural dignity
resting in that deep rootedness that we
both have in our genders that
when we are at peace with that and when
we acknowledge it in ourselves
it's there as a natural thing and and
this is the thing i don't want to make
this personal about kathy newman because
it's it's in that potential is in every
woman but it's because we are
persecuting our own femininity what's
being played out that we're doing it to
ourselves because we don't trust that
it's good enough to be a woman we don't
trust that we can have conversations
that come from a felt embodied
perspective we don't trust that we're
connected to truth
because these these
masculine ways have been have been very
strong and women have been denying their
own power
in my work over many years of working
with this i find that very few women
grew up in households which really
loved admired respected honored
cherished the feminine
and so there is intrinsically
for so many women who've grown up in the
i don't know the last hundred years
let's say um
a kind of devaluation of the feminine
that gets taken on and of course and as
well as abuse aggression all sorts of
things so very
many women out of an intelligent
strategy to survive develop their
masculine side as a defense against that
devaluation for the feminine and over
time they become very identified with
that masculine side the male equivalent
is animal possession
in anima possession
it's the loss of relaxed confidence in
groundedness in the masculine and is
overwhelmed by his own inner feminine
side and it creates a
passive withdrawn moody
complaining
not showing up kind of guy which i think
is really so much what feminists are
angry about i don't see them as really
angry about the masculine per se but at
the way that males behave and you know i
have quite a lot of compassion for that
because for myself and most men that i
know we weren't really shown
how to be as men we didn't really get
initiated into it and so and then this
strong thing comes from feminism and we
feel like it's it's maleness that's
wrong and it's not
it's not maleness that's wrong
i don't even think feminism feminists
hate
the masculine
it's like what the call is really for
men is to develop their masculine
strength presence courage
be relaxed and confident be protective
and be strong
and
under this kind of assault which has
come from a lot of animus possessed
women a lot of men have retreated and i
think gone into feeling guilty about
being men and have got become passive
indecisive
and in that way
a kind of feminized man has emerged
[Music]
those who followed peterson's thought
recognize his analysis goes all the way
down to the bedrock
to the archetypal structures of
consciousness itself the thing that i
really see happening and you can tell me
what you think about this in in
neumann's book
consciousness which is masculine
symbolically masculine for a variety of
reasons is is viewed as rising up
against the countervailing force of
tragedy from an underlying feminine
symbolically feminine unconsciousness
right and it's something that can always
be pulled back into that unconsciousness
that would be the microcosm of that
would be the freudian eatable mother
familial dynamic where the mother is so
over
uh protective and all-encompassing that
she interferes with the development of
the competence not only of her sons but
also of her daughters of her children in
general
and it seems to me that that's the
dynamic that's being played out in our
society right now is that there's this
and it's it's related in some way that i
don't understand to this to this
insistence that all forms of masculine
authority are nothing but tyrannical
power so the symbolic representation is
tyrannical father with no appreciation
for the benevolent father and benevolent
mother with no appreciation whatsoever
for the tyrannical mother right and
that's that and because i thought of
ideologies as fragmentary mythologies
that's where they get their archetypal
and psychological power right and so in
a balanced representation you have the
terrible mother and the great mother as
neumann laid out so nicely and you have
the terrible father and the great father
so that's the fact that culture mangles
you half to death well it's also
promoting you and developing you you
have to see that as balanced and then
you have the heroic and adversarial
individual but in the post-modern world
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large you have nothing but
the tyrannical father nothing but the
destructive force of masculine
consciousness and nothing but the
benevolent
benevolent great mother and it's a it's
an appalling ideology and it seems to me
that it's sucking the vitality
which is exactly what you would expect
symbolically it's sucking the vitality
of our culture you see that with the
increasing demolition of of young men
um and not only young men in terms of
their academic performance which like
they're falling way behind in elementary
school way behind in junior high and
bailing out of the universities like mad
and so and i
well the public school education has
become completely permeated by this kind
of anti-male propaganda i mean
to me public schools are just a form of
imprisonment you know right now they're
particularly destructive to young men
who have a lot of physical energy
uh now you know i identify as
transgender okay myself but i do not
i do not require the entire world to
alter itself okay to fit my particular
self-image i do believe in the power of
hormones i believe that men exist and
women exist and they are biologically
different i think that i think there is
no cure for um the culture's ills right
now except if men start standing up okay
and demanding that they be respected as
men here's the problem you know
this is something my wife has pointed
out too she said well men are going to
have to stand up for themselves but
here's the problem i know how to stand
up to a man who's
who's uh unfairly
trespassing against me and the reason i
know that is because the parameters for
my resistance are quite well defined
which is we talk we argue we push and
then it becomes physical
right like if we move beyond the
boundaries of civil discourse we know
what the next step is okay that's
forbidden in in discourse with women so
i don't know like it seems to me that it
isn't men that have to stand up and say
enough of this even though that is what
they should do it seems to me that it's
same women who have to stand up against
their crazy sisters and say look enough
of that enough man-hating enough
pathology enough bringing disgrace on us
as a as a gender
but
the problem there and then i'll stop my
little tirade is that most of the women
i know who are sane are busy doing sane
things right they're off they have their
career they have their family they're
quite occupied and they don't seem to
have the time or maybe even the interest
to go after their their crazy harpy
sisters and so i don't see any
regulating force for that that terrible
femininity and it seems to me to be
invading the culture and undermining the
the masculine power of the culture in a
way that's i think fatal i really do
believe that i too i too believe these
are symptomatic of the decline of
western culture and we and it will just
go down flat i don't think people
realize that you know masculinity still
exists okay in the world as a code among
jihadists okay and when you have
passionate masculinity okay circling the
borders like the huns and the vandals
during the roman empire that's what i
see i see this culture rotting from
within okay and disempowering itself
literally
we have i mean what advice would you
give to people to
to navigate this new world the first is
free your mind be aware of the fact that
the habits of the blue church and and
how it works
um don't work anymore recognize that
your way of making sense in the world
that used to work don't work and you
really really need to set yourself free
to begin learning a new
child's mind beginner's mind
second
this by nature must in fact be
exploratory so
swim do not
make sense prematurely in spite of the
fact that the world feels dangerous in
spite of the fact that you may want to
protect yourself
in this dangerous world
doing so too quickly
does not allow the natural exploratory
to do what it needs to do
really just listen
and learn go all the way down back down
to human base
turn inward
learn how fear shows up in you
learn how not to allow fear to drive the
choices that you make
learn how to listen to the whole way
that all of you perceives what's going
on become more integrated with your own
body
go out into nature
spend a lot of time not connected to the
chaos that's going on and a lot of time
reconnecting yourself with your
fundamental capacity to perceive reality
in all the different modalities that
human beings have the capacity to do
then we learn how to use other human
beings as allies in figuring out how to
make sense of the world
i mean that really relearn like we have
been abused and
constrained
by institutional frameworks that remove
us from our own native capabilities
so relearn that understand how to be a
friend and an ally how to have a
conversation with somebody where you're
really listening closely to get a sense
of what their perspective brings to you
where you're not obligated to agree with
them you're not obligated to move out of
what you feel is right to form some new
consensus reality but where you're
actually authentically recognizing that
their perspective has some capacity to
bring richness to your perspective
this by the way is almost exclusively
possible in person now what we're doing
right now is an okay version of it but
we need to be very mindful the fact that
linear broadcast is bad and even
interactive
bandwidth like this is not good enough
you know you've got to learn from raw
physical
and get yourself into places where your
consensus reality and your habits are
willfully destroyed get into human to
human conversations and and get as far
away from ideology as you can
your job is not to know what the is
going on your job is to be absolutely
certain that you have no idea what the
is going on and learn how to feel
from raw chaos from raw uncertainty
up
then
and only then
are you finally able to begin the
journey of
beginning to form a collective
intelligence in this new environment
that's my advice
this is why we've created rebel wisdom
to host these conversations
to try and unpack what's going on
and through our workshops and events
start to build this collective
intelligence for the future
to see longer versions of the interviews
featured in this film and our
full-length documentary about jordan
peterson check the rebel wisdom website
help us create more films about these
subjects by sponsoring us on patreon
and come to our events to have these
conversations in person
[Music]
you